Great.
Well thank you.
And it's great to see all of you.
Um,
and I want to thank Google for the invitation.
I'm,
I'm a fan of the company and have enjoyed working with all of you through the
years,
so it's good to have faces with the company.
So thank you.
Um,
and so in talking to a couple of the folks prior to this event,
uh,
the term intersectionality came up where I think all of you are focusing on the
intersection of all of our different parts of our lives and how that comes
together.
So I'm probably gonna come back to that as we,
as we talk through some of the questions and hopefully take some of your
questions.
But,
um,
just by way of introduction,
think about all the different hats I wear.
I'm,
yes,
I'm an executive during most days.
I'm also a mom of a 15 year old and three well two dogs and one cat.
I'm a wife.
I serve on a,
a national board.
I am the chair of the board of my daughter's private school and I also am a
deacon at my church.
And so you think about all the intersections of the LGBT family,
uh,
your work family,
and then all the ways we try to give back to the different parts of our lives
that are important.
So hopefully we can touch on a number of those different areas.
And I probably have other hats that I totally forgot and,
and whatnot,
but a,
but a little bit about my story.
I'm from South Louisiana,
so I am one of the real Cajuns.
Um,
even though my last name doesn't show it,
my mother was a primo and if you have any Cajun jokes,
it's the Tibideau is Boudreau's.
Primos okay.
Um,
so I am,
I'm one of those Cajun folks.
Um,
and so from a very young age,
I always knew I was different from a lot of folks.
So like many of you probably I took upon myself to be like perfect at
everything,
uh,
be the,
you know,
whatever the,
the head of everything so that once people figure it out that I was different,
they would still kind of maybe like me.
Um,
and so I took that path and I know a lot of people took similar paths in their
life.
Um,
my coming out story is kind of a funny one in that,
um,
my,
uh,
the,
the story goes like this.
I was at college and my mother called in a panic saying,
oh my God,
Renee,
you're sister is a lesbian,
but I've always known about you,
but really your sister too.
I was like,
well,
great.
Thanks mom.
And he's off.
Um,
so,
uh,
so that's an important part of kind of my story.
My parents went to for two and have a two gay kids.
My,
my sister runs the MCC church,
uh,
for a little bit.
So she's the gay pope.
So you can look up Rochelle Brown and you'll,
you'll recognize the resemblance or at least the voice.
Um,
but throughout,
uh,
throughout my career,
um,
you know,
being a lesbian,
I as you know,
starting in banking,
it's a very conservative,
um,
field.
And so I wasn't,
you know,
out there in my first several roles and it really wasn't until I,
uh,
my partner and I decided to start a family,
that the whole coming out process started in earnest because if you're pregnant
and you're coming out,
you have to come out cause you have to explain your relationship.
And so that really was,
was a real turning point,
not only in my personal life and starting a family,
but also in my professional life.
And a lot of people have said,
well,
does having a child and,
and coming out,
does it harm your career?
In my situation,
I left on maternity leave as a person on the brand team at Wacovia,
um,
and came back and they immediately said,
you're the head of brand management.
You're a senior vice president.
It starts now.
And it's like,
okay,
I did an interview for anything.
I think that's against a lot of HR policies,
but that,
you know,
I,
started in and just jumped right in.
So my experience was a very positive one,
um,
on that front.
Um,
but you know,
through my career I've been in,
in financial services,
marketing,
uh,
for a very long time.
And,
um,
I've served in a lot of different roles.
I've had a chance to do a lot of different things across financial services.
And I think a part of that is because I'm really open to taking,
taking on new challenges and new experiences.
And so as we go through some of these questions,
I hope to,
to share some of that because I think the intersections of all of our
experiences make us a better,
uh,
a better worker for whatever company we're serving at the time.
So anyway,
that's just a little bit more about my story.
Great.
Thank you.
Um,
and could you tell us a little bit more about the leadership role that you're in
now?
Um,
what are you tax tasked with and what kind of team to oversee?
And just to build on your last point,
and it would also love to hear about,
you know,
some of the challenges that you're most excited about approaching and your
current role.
Absolutely.
So I'm,
I'm running marketing for the retail side of Tia.
And so for folks not familiar with Tiaa,
it's a hundred year old company that's known for retirement and helping
universities and not for profits in their retirement space.
Um,
and we just launched into retail.
And so it's a very young part of the company.
It's really a startup with the exception.
We do have an advisor force,
which is very small,
about 850 advisors.
Um,
the last company I left had 15,000 advisors,
so a very different scale and scope and a very different way of going to
business.
Um,
but we just purchased a bank.
And so we're integrating that bank over the next several weeks.
And,
um,
the,
the goal and what my team is,
uh,
responsible for is figuring out how do we go to market differently.
We're a not for profit organization and how do we go up against the B of a
Merrill,
the chase,
uh,
others in the financial services industry like fidelity and show up differently,
um,
and show our not for profit heritage and,
and,
and really try to disrupt the marketplace.
And so that's a,
that's the challenge I'm taking on now.
I have a small team,
I haven't counted.
I don't know how many people,
probably about 50 people on the team now.
And a,
and it's really exciting because I'm,
so,
I was with Wacovia wells for 20 years and in that whole process,
um,
even in brand management,
we were constantly trying to say,
how is this company different while we're on every street corner?
Uh,
with the wells example,
we have ponies.
If we can give out plush ponies to people,
yes,
that's a thing.
Um,
but there wasn't anything like heart and soul,
whereas Tia has a soul and we're trying to uncover that and like show,
show this really cool and,
and show how it's different in the market.
So it sounds like it might be easy,
but it's going to be a challenge just with a lot of different structures we
have.
So,
um,
so yeah,
we met with our Google team a little earlier to talk a little bit about that and
so I'm excited about the opportunity.
Awesome.
Um,
and you touched on this a little bit about sort of your promotion during your
maternity leave.
Um,
but what path did you take to your current role at ta and your,
Your path to,
to this?
Um,
Gosh,
um,
I think,
you know,
some people actually had plans for their career and I definitely didn't.
Um,
the,
the only thing consistent with my journey is that I always took on a job no one
else wanted to do.
Um,
and that has been kind of my hallmark and I've,
uh,
discovered that if you raise your hand and do something,
no one else wants to do that.
Your beloved by the management because it's typically something that's hairy,
complicated political and people don't know the answer.
And even if you can get in and move it just a little bit,
people love you and you're kind of marked with that.
So I started my career,
um,
on the regular banking side doing tons of integrations in New Orleans for
Hibernia Bank,
which was bought by capital one.
So that's how long ago that was.
But it was fun being single and 26,
I live in near Bourbon Street.
And then with Wacovia was on the business,
small business side.
And that was really cool because I got to learn how business bankers go in and
help companies.
And I found that to be very fascinating.
Um,
and then when first union bought Wacovia moved into brand management and that
was a great learning,
a great ability to kind of step back and say,
how can a company be different,
but not just how it's expressed,
but how people actually behave at the company.
And that's where magic can happen with different institutions.
Uh,
but I quickly realized that everyone's a brand expert.
I don't know if y'all know that.
Um,
and I got really burned out with some of the components of branding and so no
one at the company wanted to support the financial advisors.
Um,
and because they are known as cowboys and cowgirls and mean people,
and I'm like,
I'll take that on.
So I went and got my series seven and I'm like,
okay,
I'm going to do this whole brokerage thing and retirement asset management.
And I did that for seven years,
uh,
pre and post merger.
So I'm with Wells Fargo.
And so that was,
that was really great learning.
Did the AG Edwards integration,
that was the biggest brokerage integration in history.
I was awesome.
Learned so much.
Um,
and then after that,
um,
I,
I raised my hand for another problem.
Um,
which was a wells Fargo social media was a disaster.
And so the board was kind of standing on,
uh,
the management and said,
you guys have to centralize this,
which the company didn't centralize anything at the time.
So I was the person who brought social media to gather and,
and that was really fun.
I kinda got out of marketing for those few years because as you know,
standing up a social media platform for a company that large,
you're dealing with HR issues because employees love posting things that they
should not post.
Um,
and,
and um,
PR and it was a lot less marketing than it was some of the like managing kinds
of things.
And so,
um,
I,
the last role I had at wells was actually in the community bank.
All of you know where that is right now,
so I'm happy to be a ta ta.
So,
you know,
I mean,
each of those twists and turns involved some component of no one wanted to touch
it.
Like my last role,
community banking,
no one wanted to touch that because everyone knew there were problems and things
were getting ready to blow up and that's what happened.
Um,
so
yeah.
Does that help?
Yes.
Yeah.
Um,
what was the,
just taking a step even further back,
um,
what was the first job that you ever had and did you imagine in that job that
you would find yourself here in this current role?
I think all of you would say the same thing.
Um,
I would assume so.
I had my,
I started my first job at the age of 16 on my birthday at 6:00 AM I was a radio
announcer and the reason is my sister was radio announcer and we sound a lot
alike.
And so that's how I got my first job because I sounded like my sister.
Um,
but she continued in radio for a lot longer than than I did.
But,
um,
that,
that was really great.
I learned a lot.
I,
I did radio announcing from that age into college and I was actually a traffic
reporter in baton rouge where there's awful traffic if,
if y'all have ever been through there,
you know,
but I actually flew in the airplane every morning and every night and I was
uptown Renee brown for a long time,
um,
through graduate school and,
and you know,
every job I ever did.
And during college I was,
I took any job I could work my way through college.
I was a receptionist for an architectural firm.
I worked at the library,
you know,
you name it just to,
to get money because believe it or not being a radio announcer written very
lucrative.
Um,
but what I learned,
uh,
announcing traffic in particular is you have 30 seconds and you know,
sometimes you'd have to interstate shut down.
You had all this stuff to say and you had 30 seconds to get it done.
And how did that translate some my later jobs,
I mean some of my roles and you've all experienced that,
you know,
you go in for a big presentation with somebody and they want the 32nd version.
And so to have that experience of saying,
okay,
I have 30 seconds,
what are the three things I can say in 30 seconds?
And believe it or not,
that has been very helpful for my career.
So even though,
you know,
knowing media and that side of media has been helpful for my marketing career,
um,
that's the piece that probably was the biggest learning for me as a,
as a younger person growing up.
But I did also learn a lot and radio of exactly what not to do from an HR sexual
harassment standpoint,
very different industries.
Um,
and then pivoting towards,
and again,
you're an out LGBTQ identifying woman.
Um,
how do you feel like identifying as an Lgbtq woman or generally more broader as
a woman has positively or negatively affected your career in your,
your growth?
You know,
I think,
um,
one thing that's true across LGBT and other diverse segments is I think,
people gain more empathy growing up when you are the subordinated group for the
majority of your upbringing or your lifetime.
Um,
and so understanding what it feels like to not in the dominant group and having
empathy and,
and tracking.
Because I used to,
um,
pay attention a lot to people's emotions in the room.
I think some of you probably have experienced that too,
to kind of sense when things are going in the wrong direction and redirect them.
Um,
and,
and so I think that empathy is critical for anybody who's a leader of people to
really understand how to read a situation and,
and use that,
that level of empathy and also knowing how to be,
um,
both,
uh,
aware when you're in the dominant group.
And how do you help people that aren't,
is,
is an awareness level that a lot of people don't have.
Because usually when you're in a dominant group and you have power and authority
and all that stuff,
you're unaware of it.
And,
and the best place to look at this as airport.
We were kidding around about airports.
It's so fun when like something happens and everyone gets messed up with a
flight.
It's fun to watch the super privileged people freak out and just lose their mind
because they're being inconvenienced.
And that's a sure example of,
you know,
people who are very unaware that they have all this privilege.
Um,
and once they're put in a position without it,
they don't even know how to deal with the world around them.
And so I think,
you know,
for me,
um,
being an LGBT leader and a,
and a female leader,
um,
you know,
I kind of try to carry all that background of when I wasn't an executive and I
didn't have the power or authority and how do I use that for good as I've,
as I've moved through my career
career.
Great.
Um,
do you recall a moment in your career,
in your life when you realize that being visibly out would actually be an asset
to you,
either as a,
in your career or in your work with nonprofits on boards,
etc.
Yeah,
you know,
I,
I think probably the,
the moment when,
you know,
for a long time I was the executive sponsor of,
of LGBT groups at Wacovia and then at wells and when we transitioned over to
wells,
there was a lot of conversation and,
and uh,
no one really wanted to go talk to the head of compensation around the whole
gross up.
This was before domestic when we had domestic partner benefits and,
and you needed to gross up people's tax taxes on healthcare for their partners.
Um,
and,
and that was the moment where I realized I had access,
I knew the head of HR,
I knew this guy in compensation and the people in the,
in the Erg didn't have that access.
And it's like,
okay,
this is,
this is a win win because I can go knock on a door and open a door and have a
conversation that's different because we're working with one another on
different things,
not just this.
Um,
and so that's,
that's a real asset.
And what I found,
I have found through the years is a lot of times there are LGBT folks who are
not out at higher levels.
And that's a real shame because they're missing an opportunity and,
and,
and you know,
other diverse groups aren't as supportive one to another.
And that's a shame because that's where we can really have a voice and,
and be able to have conversations differently.
And so,
um,
that's how I've seen it as an asset,
as to open doors for others who,
who weren't able to do that.
Um,
have you ever experienced adversity and kind of the converse side as a result of
being out work?
And would you
be okay sharing one of those stories with us?
Sure.
And this is probably less at work.
It's probably more,
um,
uh,
a side effect of being so comfortable at the office.
And so,
um,
this situation happened.
I don't know what the year was,
but I was,
um,
getting in a taxi and Saint Louis heading to the airport.
Um,
uh,
you know,
the Ag Edwards,
now wells Fargo Securities Headquarters is in St Louis.
And so I'm getting the taxi,
you know,
normal chit chat conversation with the driver.
And he said,
okay,
so what does your husband do?
I said,
I don't have a husband,
I have a wife and she stays home with our child.
And he left the interstate and went someplace that I knew wasn't on the way to
the airport.
So I realized,
great,
I just totally got some guide and he's going to go chop me up and little bits
and pieces.
And so I immediately got on the phone with HR and just to,
I was just chatting with my HR partner cause I'm like,
I'm going to be on the phone with somebody while whatever happens happens.
And he wound up driving through a park and then getting back on track.
But he was very,
he did not appreciate the fact that I was very out and,
and honest about,
you know,
my personal situation.
And so that was like lesson for me,
like within the walls of your workplace.
You can be very honest and sometimes in other places it's good to say,
you know,
um,
whatever,
not answer the question.
Um,
but yeah,
that was,
that was one big learning for me.
That got me a little bit worried.
Am I can,
I can definitely say I've had similar Uber experiences.
Um,
yeah.
Uh,
how do you and your wife and Balance Your career and your family?
You know,
I don't know if if,
um,
there ever really is work life balance.
A lot of people ask that question and um,
I think there's times of throttling up where you're completely out of balance
and it's needed at whatever time that is in your career.
I mean,
if you fundamentally change jobs or change companies,
it's not like you're going to have a whole lot of work life balance.
And so I think it's important just to name that,
but you can't always have the out of balance kind of situation.
And it's not always throttling up and spending 20 hours a day.
And so we have routines like many others.
Um,
you know,
whether it's the Sunday evening dinners or,
um,
another work life balance thing is,
is actually turning the phone off.
I do stop in the evenings and have some quiet time,
particularly as my daughter has gotten older now,
she's 15.
She's taller than me.
She's smarter than me.
Literally.
She,
her sat score is way better than mine was as a senior already.
And so,
um,
but it's harder to have a team talk to you.
And so we have to really make time and have quiet time as a family in the
evenings to actually have a conversation happen.
Um,
and then the other piece is we do take vacations and so I was telling them I'm
heading out next Wednesday,
which is a little stressful.
Um,
we're going to go on a two week vacation and that's,
um,
it's critical to actually get some downtime,
because you know,
it's easy to let both relationship and family kind of fall apart with all the
things pulling at you from your work.
And so we try not to have that happen.
I don't know if we're successful all the time though.
No one's no one's perfect.
And you had mentioned your sister and also that you serve as a deacon for,
um,
your church.
How does religion come into your life and especially since it can oftentimes be
perceived as,
but by members of the Lgbtq community as being at times at odds with being LGBTQ
identified and being open about it.
So we'd love to hear how you address that with your own identity and with your
own faith.
Yeah,
I thought that would,
it would
be an interesting area and I don't know if that's something all of you have seen
at Google but with other other companies and other Erg is working without an
equal for example.
It's,
it's interesting that as companies expand and get faith [inaudible] that people
see that there'd be a conflict between a faith employee resource group and an
LGBT resource group or LGBT and military has all kinds of like interesting
thoughts around different diverse groups and where they might agree or disagree
and have a very different perspective on it.
Particularly in the last year and a half.
Um,
as we've seen all diverse groups attacked,
um,
equally by the administration,
by parts of the media where,
you know,
if you're a person with disability,
somebody is picking on you,
you're person of color,
LGBT,
you name it,
everyone seems to be under attack.
And so as we think about all these different degree diverse groups,
I think we as a collective need to figure out how to work together and,
and really help the cause of anybody who's diverse.
And so I think that's critical and I don't think we've figured it out.
I mean,
if you think of all the diverse groups in the country,
if we all actually got together,
we would have a huge voice against what's happening in our society right now.
And,
and folks who aren't doing that.
And I think it's,
it's a,
it's an opportunity.
Um,
and with religion specifically,
that's where I've had the most dialogue across difference with folks because I
welcome people having a conversation who might feel like their religion says
that they can't support LGBT Q folks.
And so those have been difficult conversations,
but everyone has,
has helped kind of move forward just a little bit.
Um,
my upbringing,
I spent three days a week in a church that,
that,
um,
really thought LGBT folks,
we're going to hell and set at seven,
said it frequently.
So I was,
I was damaged by my early childhood religious experience.
And so it wasn't until we started a family and my,
my wife made me go to church.
Um,
and we shopped for a church and found one and it took,
you know,
years of healing honestly to be in a church that,
um,
basically feels the same way.
Pro Pope Francis fields is that all of us are made in God's image and loved
equally.
And,
and um,
it takes a long time to heal from some of the scars if you've heard other tapes
in your head throughout outre upbringing.
And so I just wanted to name that.
And then my sister being a minister and,
and uh,
reverend and leading a church,
um,
I think it's important and important thing to name.
Cause I know other LGBT folks who left any semblance of faith out of their lives
for any number of reasons.
Um,
you know,
pride parades,
people hollering and screaming at you,
things like that.
It can be very disconcerting,
but you know,
times have changed.
And I think it's time for us to have good dialogue and a real understanding of
different areas of faith and open up,
you know,
dialogue between an Lgbtq Erg and a faith Erg and,
and be visible in that because to say I'm a Christian Lesbian Christian,
I'm very comfortable saying that,
uh,
now,
now years ago I wasn't for any number of reasons,
but I just think that's an important dialogue that a lot of companies aren't,
aren't having that conversation.
And it sounds like also,
you know,
based on your earlier come and go out with a story,
then it's something your sister also deals with and her faith as well.
Yeah.
Yup.
Great.
Um,
and you also touched on this in terms of working together as different minority
groups.
Um,
but how do you,
it's easy to talk about in practice,
you know,
like how,
or in theory of how do at different employee resource groups work together.
How do different minority groups work together and you know,
their,
their strength together is greater than the sum of each of the individual parts.
But,
you know,
how does that,
how does it work and how can employee resource groups and different minority
groups work together effectively to advocate for one another and you see that
working?
I think having a common set of goals is probably the most critical component.
And,
and having,
um,
we've had so many events in society of late that could be rallying cries for
groups of different Erg has to come together and do an event or,
or have some kind of activity that could be meaningful.
Um,
you know,
you think of Charlottesville and,
and what,
what are the Lgbtq ers doing when situations like that happen?
And I think that's the consciousness that needs to kind of come up.
Um,
I've seen some companies pull members of each of the diverse args and have
dialogue across those,
um,
like,
you know,
the Asian American group,
um,
to include parts of the world that someone might think a military person might
not want to sit by them.
Um,
or you know,
have an Lgbtq military veteran,
have a conversation with somebody in a faith group,
you know,
all of those kind of mixing and matching this diverse it,
it kind of creates a tension.
Um,
and so having panels like that is something that I would recommend.
and then with my work with out and equal,
we're doing a lot of focus on companies who are international in scope because,
um,
as you know,
as you move out of the US,
there are a lot of countries where if you move different employees around and
they aren't out,
it can be very challenging for them.
Um,
in countries where you could get killed for being LGBT.
And so we're working through trying to help give resources to institutions on
how do you facilitate those kinds of interactions and how do you work in a
country like India that has laws that prohibit a lot of,
um,
uh,
you know,
openness around people's,
um,
you know,
Lgbtq orientation.
So,
um,
that's,
that's it.
An emerging space that isn't going to change because our world keeps getting
smaller and smaller and,
and those kinds of issues will continue to come up.
Um,
and also the other thing I'd name that that is,
uh,
a growing space is,
is the,
our,
our next generation,
which I'm sure all of you have plenty of,
um,
Gen z here at the Google headquarters.
Um,
you know,
when we think about that generation,
the,
the gender fluidity and,
and issues at,
at work around that and the lack of understanding of senior leaders of most
companies around that space is,
is really critical.
I mean,
I've gotten some questions that I.
Dot.
I didn't even know the answer to,
which is my own learning that I have to keep,
keep growing and learning in that space.
Um,
so anyway,
um,
that's,
those are all areas that I know out in equals focused on and a lot of companies
are trying to make sure there is education and understanding across that.
Yeah.
And actually touching on the out and equal piece again,
um,
how does your position as an executive affect how you approach organizations
like out of an equal,
your service there and other causes that you support?
Yeah.
You know,
um,
I,
I have served on the board of the Red Cross for years and,
and part of the reason for that is just a being from south Louisiana and having
hurricanes in the backyard every,
every weekend just about,
um,
and,
and seeing the fact that that organization is always there for people no matter
what.
And,
and the Red Cross and Red Crescent internationally as an amazing organization.
Um,
and I just kind of,
my values,
I share values with that organization.
Um,
I moved from that group over to out and equal and it's been a really great
learning for me.
And one of the things I've appreciated is just the ability to meet people across
industries who are making a difference in their organizations and,
and helping not only LGBTQ causes but a lot of others.
Um,
and so that's been invaluable for me.
and in fact that organization out in equal just had a new CEO come in.
Really exciting.
We're going to be,
I'm having a strategic offsite and Disney in a month and I'm looking forward to
that.
I think we're going to blaze a new path because out in equals known for their
summit,
which is going to be in Seattle in October.
Um,
but also we have to do more webinars.
We have a lot more education.
There's a lot more that we have to do and catch up with the times because you
guys know in person summit's a really hard for people to get to.
Of course the gamblers have always been allowed group at summits.
I will,
I will give you that.
I could take that.
Um,
and so,
um,
anyway,
so yeah,
and,
and you know,
uh,
I find,
board work,
whether I helped our church with long range planning or I'm now leading the
board of my daughter's school as I mentioned,
um,
I find that a great distraction and a great learning.
So I'm oftentimes when life,
so I've been in marketing a million years and it's not that I'm not learning in
the role,
but,
um,
I don't get to get out of that box as often.
So,
um,
right now our school is buying property and going through all the rezoning and
doing all kinds of things that it's like I don't have a chance to do that.
So I find it stimulating and interesting.
Um,
and also it,
it,
it helps to put a face with that group in particular,
a phase to the LGBT world in a different way for those parents of other kids.
And I think we have to do that.
We have to be out in our communities and,
um,
serving in roles that might not be as expected.
And I think it just helps people know.
It's like,
okay,
me and my wife,
we have kind of the same life that all the other parents around the table have.
We are,
uh,
you know,
doing the best we can.
I'm trying to deal with all the things that you faced with a teenager and I'm
comparing notes on does this work or not?
Um,
you know,
going through the circle of life and to share that with,
um,
with people who are not in our core Lgbtq community is critical.
So,
um,
I,
and I also,
I learned a lot from the process.
Great.
And I know we,
that was the end of my formal questions here,
but,
um,
I know we had some questions with a dory and I think one of them in particular,
just to touch back on a comment that you'd made earlier was about advice that
you would give to young people in your career.
And you had mentioned that,
um,
specifically in your career,
you always found it to be very helpful to take on kind of that big hairy role
that no one wanted to take on.
So I'd love to hear a little bit more about sort of,
you know,
the,
obviously there's a huge opportunity that comes with taking on something that's
challenging and,
and potentially has high visibility but also a lot of risk associated with that.
So we'd love to hear a little bit more about how you've also balanced kind of
the risk associated with taking some of those challenging roles,
uh,
along with the opportunity.
Yeah,
and
you know,
probably taking on social media and wells was probably the highest stakes one.
The ones prior to that were more,
okay,
no one that's a gap that needs to be filled and I'm going to go fill that gap.
Um,
but,
but in that role,
it was really,
really clear that the company was on the wrong path and they were like huge
issues going on.
Um,
that if any auditor would come in,
it would be a flaming disaster.
In fact,
our internal audit showed up two weeks after I started and freaked me out
completely.
So instead of resisting them,
I just brought him in and said,
okay,
here's everything I've seen.
Um,
you know,
we have no exit strategies,
we have no strategies for any platform,
we have no controls,
no governance.
It was just,
you know,
you name it,
everything that would freak somebody out.
And,
and I,
I took it as an opportunity to say audit,
can you help me put this together in the right way?
And they did and they were fabulous and they only,
they didn't dig me too badly on that,
um,
on that survey.
But it was a huge risk.
And the way I balanced that as,
as I took the role on,
I went and talked to several executives at the company and I said,
look,
there's a lot of people see this as play time or not serious or something to be
controlled.
And you guys know,
social media can't be controlled.
And that was part of my challenge is talking to the baby boomers who were trying
to control the,
the,
the younger generation.
And it was so clear that you can't control it.
And it's so clear also in our society,
things can be right and wrong at the same time depending on what perspective you
take on issue.
And so translating that was a critical part of my role.
But I talked to a lot of executives and just said,
how do I,
how do I take on this,
this effort?
And the resoundingly feedback that I got is used risk as the key because if you
can outline all the risks associated with what's happening and how to mitigate
them,
they're going to give you a blank check.
And that's exactly what happened.
The company said,
okay,
what,
what number do you need?
And so we were eight.
We opened,
you know,
command centers on both coasts and set up the entire system the way it should be
set up.
And the really unfortunate thing about that is the command centers weren't used
until everyone found out about sales practices issues at the company.
And so that was a,
that was when the command centers really came into use.
But I'm glad,
at least I was there to put that together for the company.
I would have preferred the company use those for something really positive as
opposed to,
um,
a huge,
uh,
Dang for the brand that they may never recover from.
Now.
Um,
but you know,
that was,
that was the biggest risk in taking on something that was Harry.
Um,
and I think,
you know,
getting the counsel of many different people,
um,
and,
and being clear on what is the role and what are the truths and non truths and
how do they all come together and how then can you articulate it to the
audiences where it makes sense,
whether that's the board of directors or the employee who thinks I'm talking
about smoking joints.
Um,
during office hours is a good idea.
We had a lot of that.
Well,
that's,
uh,
that's definitely an interesting note to end on a,
for the formal questions.
Um,
but I wanted to open it up before we go to the dory,
to anyone in the room who would have a question or we can switch it over.
Uh,
one of the questions I have is it,
I really admire the sense of responsibility.
It seems that you have as,
um,
identifying as Lgbtq and,
kind of taking that on.
And I'd be curious to know where in,
you know,
if there was sort of like a moment where you,
you felt that responsibility or if it,
if it,
you know,
maybe it was more acquainted to um,
maturity or where during your,
your life or career that you said,
wow.
Like I really need to make sure that I use my voice.
Yeah.
Thank you for the question.
And then I think I would go back to when I,
um,
supported,
that large brokerage firm.
And so anybody knowing,
um,
Wall Street brokerage firms,
they're mainly male and typically 56,
I'm sure that age is higher now.
Um,
and pretty much straight with only very few exceptions.
And so it was in that role that I realized,
you know,
I really need to show up not only as a,
as a female leader,
but also be authentic and at,
you know,
and one of the ways that that was made easy for me that I should name is that
having a kid is an equalizing force to where you can,
um,
you know,
really connect with somebody if they also have kids and just talk about their
children and that situation.
You don't have to name the family structure or anything,
but it just makes a common,
you have some common ground there.
That I found was a really important platform that then I could use to kind of
explain the differences between our families.
Um,
when there were differences.
I mean,
now thank goodness there are so many different things where I'm actually married
as opposed to when we weren't.
And you know,
the financial situations my family had,
were very different from the people I would be talking to.
Um,
and sometimes I had a chance to do that kind of education,
you know,
that moment.
Um,
but it was then when then when I realized,
okay,
I can create a common ground with people who probably had never talked to a
lesbian,
um,
leader before honestly,
or saw them in any way where there was some kind of common ground.
And,
and that's where I kind of,
it's submitted for me that I need to be a leader and show up in the right way
it's been,
and then also I started,
you know,
as you start getting older in your career,
you realize people younger than you are actually watching you.
And so I feel a responsibility around that where it's like,
you know,
I need to handle myself in a way that that is something that people would want
to follow.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you again,
so much for coming and talking today.
Um,
my question for you is how do you think that,
um,
the folks running the LGBT Erg is,
can best engage with more senior folks,
especially given that time is,
um,
frequently difficult to come by as folks get more and more senior in their
career?
Yeah,
that's a great question.
And one of the things that really surprised me when I joined Tia last year,
we had a panel,
um,
you know,
LGBT panel and I think it was,
uh,
it was on coming out day.
It was October 11th last year.
And,
uh,
what really surprised me is as the panel started in,
walked the entire executive committee,
our CEO and all of his direct reports except for maybe two who couldn't make it.
And that was the first time in any of the time I've done this.
And,
and the two decades I've been playing around with this stuff that the entire
executive committee,
uh,
joined in LGBT event.
And that just floored me and it was really impactful.
It made me realize,
you know,
Tia really walks the talk around,
the importance of all of the Erg is because they do,
they would do that with other employee resource groups.
And so I don't think that is unusual for the company,
but I think that's something where you guys should ask leadership to actually
join and be visible in different events.
Cause because that goes a long way.
Um,
in particularly if they might,
certain ones,
certain folks might show up for some events and not others.
It,
it tells a story about who's not present.
Um,
so that would be one thing is making sure that the leadership is present but
finding the right network.
So I'm sure within how many employees do you guys have at Google?
Oh really?
Okay.
I thought it would be a little bit bigger.
Um,
if you think about the entire organization,
you know,
have you guys mapped out where the rising leaders are and really making sure
that they have a voice and are using their voice both for LGBT and otherwise.
Um,
that's important.
And with talent review,
I'm sure your company does talent reviews where people go through and say who's
the upcoming talent?
And they always flag whether they are in a diverse group.
You've got to advocate to have a rainbow on there.
And so I'm doing that now at our company.
It's complicated because there's legal issues around it.
But you know,
if you just are showing of somebodies a female and whether they're a person of
color,
that's great.
But we also need to have the LGBT thing there because that's one of the reasons
people don't come out.
They don't see it as an advantage as they're moving up in their career.
So advocating as an Erg to have talent reviews include people who are openly,
uh,
willing to share that.
Because to me,
you know,
I hired a friend of mine who's an African American gay man.
I'm like,
that's a twofer.
We need to get a double bonus points for that.
Um,
and so anyway,
advocating for that at the company is important because every diverse group that
somebody has within them,
that every additional one is more experience around things that all of us need
to learn from.
So those are,
those are some of the thoughts I have.
But engaging your senior leadership to attend events is a very,
um,
outward display of support that I would recommend.
And the vein of the question that you just answered.
Um,
how do you think that your own rise over the years have effected your ability to
do what you just said,
advocate,
um,
whatnot?
You know?
Um,
I,
I find that I've been very lucky in my career as I've moved up,
but honestly I think a lot of it is a lot of hard work.
Just like all of you have experienced that,
um,
you have to do a ton of hard work and a ton of caring for people and then doors
are open for you.
Um,
um,
but you know,
having a voice on Lgbt,
I'll tell you,
I've had many situations where I've come really close to not saying anything.
Being the person in the room saying,
excuse me.
You know,
you just use language that really isn't appropriate and can be offensive to
people.
Um,
you know,
that's important.
But what one thing I would tell you is,
it was about midway through my career that I realized I have less a voice on
Lgbtq matters than I do watching out for my people of color because I'm not a
person of color.
I have more of a voice going after something.
If I see an issue around that because I have no nothing to gain in it.
Whereas some people will see all that's just the angry lesbian or the angry gay
man fussing about something.
So that's why I kind of point out how do we help other Erg is how can we give
voice to people who don't have voices.
And I think that's where power comes in.
So I try to go beyond being an LGBT leader to being,
I'm a leader trying to help diversity at the company and inclusion,
which is super critical because when you get to the point of inclusion,
it goes to a lot of things that a lot of companies don't talk about.
It gets to help people look,
it gets to their social class and social status.
Uh,
it gets to wait.
It gets to,
you know,
let's start naming things that cause people to be in the outgroup.
That's that area of inclusion is something that,
you know,
all of us who understand or have ever been on the receiving end of being
excluded for something,
we all have to be a voice to make sure everyone is included in things because
that's how companies do a better job.
Teams do a better job.
So,
you know,
I'd say yes,
I've had a voice with LGBT,
but I've seen more power helping other groups that I'm not a member of every
day.
But you do have what you have over the years.
Like more,
more recently.
Do you feel like you are more or less able to do that because of the roles that
you take now?
More able.
Yeah.
I mean the more resources you have,
the more budget you have.
It's really great.
Like,
so yeah,
I can write a time.
It's not an issue.
Uh,
well I mean we make time for whatever's important.
Right?
Yeah.
Okay,
good.
Yeah,
no what I mean,
uh,
time management.
It's funny.
Um,
we can get as much done as,
as we prioritize.
Yeah.
Hi.
So I guess there's something to be said for if somebody is in one of the
companies that you work at that's in an Erg at,
at Google or Tia or wherever,
then it's almost that that person is,
is I guess already in,
in a position of more privilege than someone else because they do have a seat at
the table.
So how do you advocate for those people,
whether they're in the queer community or people of color or really any of these
intersectional groups who don't have that seat at the table?
When we look out at our Erg is they're not there because for various reasons and
our society,
they haven't been afforded that opportunity to even to even be here,
not having the access to the social capital,
the educational capital to even get,
get somewhere like here to have that voice.
How do you advocate for this people that are basically outside of the system?
That's a great question.
I don't know if I have an answer for that one.
I would love to.
Can you help me figure it out?
I'll try it.
That'd be awesome.
Yeah,
but no,
I,
I agree with you there,
there,
um,
as our society has spread from the haves and have nots,
it's even more of an issue where,
um,
being able to figure out how to get people out of situations where they feel
completely,
um,
without any power to change anything is,
is very hard.
So thank you for the question.
But I,
yeah,
that would answer.
I appreciate the honest answer cause I don't,
I don't know if anyone does have,
have the answer.
I guess we have to work on that.
Yeah.
That's what we're thinking of the next generation is going to do.
Because the next generation is always smarter than the last one.
Yes sir.
I have one more question.
Um,
so I feel like just hearing you speak,
you know,
you'll have this like amazing confidence about your identity and,
um,
sort of your role and you talked about sort of what made you out,
like come out in the workplace.
But I guess my question is more how have you,
have you or have you always had that confidence or has it developed over time?
Um,
especially,
I guess along with how General Perceptions of,
uh,
LGBT Q people have changed.
Yeah,
that's a good question.
I mean,
I think I've always enjoyed being a leader and I've had some level of
confidence,
um,
but not,
not with myself personally.
Um,
it probably,
you know,
I was probably 26 before I really was comfortable with myself.
And it's,
um,
I think that whole process of coming out and talking to people and saying,
being honest with people,
because for so long I wasn't fully honest with people.
And,
um,
you know,
just a funny story.
Um,
when I was pregnant and I'd walk into rooms,
I had this job where I had to meet with all kinds of people.
And when you're obviously pregnant,
it's just the same question every time.
It's like,
oh,
Renee,
you're pregnant.
Congratulations.
I didn't know you were married.
And I'd say,
well,
I'm not married.
And they would be like,
okay,
what do I say now?
Oh,
she was just a,
yeah.
Um,
and then I would just start talking and,
you know,
and,
and helping them understand the whole,
the whole story.
But I had to do that over and over and over and over again.
And if I didn't have to do that,
I don't think I would've gotten as comfortable as quickly because it was like it
was awkward and all of that stuff.
And then,
you know,
it gave me a platform.
And so anyway,
it was almost like,
uh,
you know,
not being a straight person is not a good thing.
It's not something you'd put on your resume or that your parents are proud of.
And so,
you know,
it takes a lot of years before you're like,
okay,
this is me.
It's who I am.
I'm doing cool stuff.
Um,
you know,
and I'm good with myself.
So I think it takes actually being comfortable with yourself and,
and getting through all that,
you know,
and some people never are or,
or people around them don't let them be comfortable with themselves.
But thank you for that
question.
Great.
I Dunno,
I dunno if we had any other questions in the room or questions from the dory
that maybe we,
um,
we didn't cover off yet,
but the Dory
I can ask what's the story?
Yeah,
that'd be great.
So,
uh,
this too,
I think the two that we didn't really touch on because I already touched on like
what you would say to start younger in your career,
it's more,
and I think you have broached this a little bit,
but,
um,
for sort of the next generation of folks,
who are identify as queer,
um,
what are,
which issues do you see as high as parity in the workplace?
Education is probably the top one because there's so much confusion around what,
what does that mean?
If somebody says,
I'd like to be,
uh,
you know,
referred to as they,
for somebody who's a baby and I'm like,
what in the hell are you doing?
What's going on with the whole Pronoun thing?
And how do we educate in a way that,
that helps people not feel like this is,
um,
some sort of change that isn't needed.
And so I think that that dialogue across a very different perspective is
important for the next generation.
I mean,
how do you explain,
um,
a lot of the continuums people are on related to gender,
and explain it in a way that doesn't completely freak people out to where they
shut down.
Um,
and I think that's the biggest challenge in this space because it is changed to
some fundamental pieces that the,
particularly the boomer and older generations have held as capital t truth.
And,
you know,
our next generation is questioning all of that capital t truth.
Um,
and I like that.
I think it's,
I think it's awesome.
So I would just try to say,
how do you,
how do we educate in a way that's meaningful and actually have some friends
working on a concept that could really help with that?
Um,
and it's called identity diversity and it helps understand all the elements of,
um,
gender,
sexual orientation expression.
Because all of those things can be confusing if you,
if you don't know how to think about them.
And so I'm working with them to kind of get that out into different workplaces
to help explain and kind of get into,
um,
gender fluidity isn't something to be scared of.
Um,
and,
and all of that.
So,
but we need to figure out how to educate would be my answer.
It's Kinda tall.
I,
I'm wondering,
it's a lot of responsibility like you said,
to educate people,
to take moments and think about what's a teachable moment,
what's inappropriate moment when you hold back?
What's a question that you wish people would ask you more often that
enable you a platform that you could speak about?
Something that people are uncomfortable to ask you either professionally or
related to LBG.
Tq.
Yeah.
You know,
uh,
um,
I think,
differences in family is one of the ones that I find interesting because we
didn't know starting a family what might be different and,
and come to find out,
you know,
it's really not,
um,
you know,
cause when you have a,
a teething baby,
somebody in here has a teething baby.
I remember talking us.
Um,
doesn't matter if you're straight,
gay,
be any anywhere on the continuum.
It's still a teething baby.
And to be able to have people that you can come together with an and ask help
for.
So that whole family pieces is one.
Um,
but I've had some people ask some pretty crazy questions and so there's always
interest in,
you know,
uh,
conception.
It's like you wouldn't ask that of anybody else.
And so they're also,
you know,
so there's a,
there's an to some extremes people go to around,
um,
around different things.
So,
um,
I don't know if there's ever been a question people aren't asking enough about,
but yeah.
Yeah.
But the whole family piece is probably important and definition of families have
changed so substantially in our society where,
you know,
um,
having an LGBT family,
that was our experience in the childbirth.
We kind of thought people might be weird at the hospital.
And this was back in 2003.
Um,
and it's like,
it was quite the opposite.
All the nurses were like,
we were just so happy.
More than one parent is here because they,
a lot of people coming in who are single parents going into a situation,
it's going to be really tough.
And so they're like,
we don't care what the makeup of the family is,
as long as there's more people to help the child,
which I found fascinating.
It was real interesting learning for me there.
Yeah.
And I'm also raising a,
a straight ally,
so I hope I do a good job with that.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Well,
thank you again so much for your time today for being so open and
Sharon [inaudible].